hey guys it's dance defend I think here
and I'm Damon Griffin your resident
comic book in a video game guru and this
is our review of Captain America the
Winter Soldier which is basically
Captain America too right so let's start
off I really liked it I thought it had
great action a good storyline and a lot
of great chemistry between all the
characters what did you think I thought
the same I thought it was it was
excellent it was one of my favorite I'm
all closed for our science my favorite
Marvel individuals I'm a really big fan
but that's just this is a personal thing
but I'm not putting that aside I love
this movie
I think Marvel's just they have
confidence they're just moving they're
not intimidated by anything right now
they're just moving forward I mean it's
such a good action in here good story
good more spy thriller than I am in who
were telling me that but I was like I
was really surprised like I love the
Marvel films because even though it's
got this whole cinematic universe
they're giving the directors freedom and
writers to kind of do what they want
like this is not for and it was not you
know it's it's own thing Thor does what
it does and this does what it does I
think this it was a great great movie
yeah I rank it up high up there in the
wall Marvel comic book movies and I
still you know I think some people were
trying to debate if it was better than
the Dark Knight I personally don't think
so I still you know like The Dark Knight
more right and I still even like the
Avengers a little bit more as well right
and as far as like the individual ones
I still like Iron Man one the first one
just has a special place in my heart
right but it is up there right we're
saying that we mean yeah we still love
it it's just maybe not the best and I
think Dark Knight I think is a wrong
comparison yeah I think if anything this
is more of a spice a lot I mean I know
this is a stretch I would almost like to
look at it from the eyes of a Jason
Bourne or a James Bond because it has
that you know great spy novel feel to it
as opposed cuz Dark Knight is just so
different you know it's even though it's
a superhero genre
it's just Christopher Nolan it's very
different very different universe but
they did a great job me and Chris Evans
is really owning this role I liked the
first food was okay yeah it was probably
my least favorite is one of my favorite
but he's really owned it in this one
he's so into the role right now yeah
even in Avengers II you don't have that
much of him well where this this one we
really get
see much more depth yeah from his
character I think the stories I mean one
of the things even though I still like
Avengers a little bit more the things
that Captain America too has over is it
does have a better story the game and
your story is silly yeah the story's
better yeah there's more character
development yeah his character and for
especially Nick Fury I mean Nick Fury
yeah he was great in this he was really
we've never seen him like this before in
any of the movies because he's always
been kind of a limited role of a
caricature like he just kind of comes on
with his birds like I'm Sam Jackson but
you know I mean does he Sam Jackson but
this one was much more personal role for
him much more personal that's bigger he
actually has something to do right for
he just comes in it says it blah you
know Avengers he obviously had a bigger
role than he had before in other movies
but this is the first time where he
actually did something you know yeah you
know they tried to kill him he you know
he was fighting and all that stuff so he
actually was part of the movie this
almost makes you this is almost like a
Captain America slash shield movie yeah
you know and it makes you mini Avengers
hate to keep bash on the television show
but this shows you how good it can be
done how I'm granted I know it can't the
show can't match the budget but this
shows you how good spy espionage like
all that stuff you know spy pillars can
because it can be done really well this
movie did it
shield struggles without the television
show and this is the better version of
shield the shield I want to see well
what's gonna be interesting is the next
right which I am you do to check on oh
well there's gonna be a ton of people
who have never seen the show or people
who stopped watching it they're gonna
watch this next episode right this is
the big one likes agent Sitwell that you
see won't say what happens to no but you
see him in the previous shield episode
gets called away to do something now
he's in in this movie won't see what
happens but I mean yeah yeah so I think
a lot of people are gonna be paying
attention that next episode if they do
it right they can keep people watch
might be good yeah it could be good it
changes a lot of stuff I love the
chemistry between Chris Evans and scar
Johansson yeah the American aqua that's
one of my favorite things I thought
Falcon was off he was great Anthony
Mackie did agree brought a lot of humor
and then also I actually like the Falcon
outfit you know it was good it was
practical and I like how they kind of
organize that so I didn't have to
explain that's like learn he wasn't
learning to be a superhero they they
kind of don't say what happened to kind
of ties and things in where it's like he
just gets it and cut it's got to
business I mean this movies what to to
tars in 15 minutes I think so it's got
some time but it just it just flows it's
a nice flow to it and I love Marvel not
of action like the action and whenever
it gets a little too serious they always
throw some humor yeah just like throw
the dark well it's not quite as funny is
nor the dark world but it had still had
that Marvel humor to it that Josh Whedon
kind of banter a little bit well I like
the the action was very hyper realistic
versus Avengers and I'm not saying which
one's better cuz I love all right right
Avengers the action is more over-the-top
comic-book superhero type of stuff and
this was more like hand to hand but
obviously you know hyper it's
exaggerated especially cuz there's
people with powers even the people who
don't have her like Black Widow right
yeah when she's coming down and killing
people you know like a regular person
because she her technically her
characters supposed to be a regular
person right and it was nice and this
isn't a spoiler to say I mean I don't
think because we know George st. Pierre
is in the movie yeah George st. Pierre
fights in the movie why else would you
have yeah why else would you have a UFC
fighter in a movie so but the fight
scene between them is great there's a
lot of good hand-to-hand combat you know
George st. Pierre has that you Ultimate
Fighting training so is this really good
fight choreography great fight
choreography yeah I like it
a lot of good stuff I mean my only real
like negative is is I thought the
villain was kind of it was predictable
you know you kind of you could tell from
the trailer who the villain was gonna be
right and that's how it happened now
what I thought was interesting that was
cool and I'm sure you probably got it
cuz then it's not actually saw it I mean
he saw before dittmeyer but we went out
the second time he saw was in the same
theater same night opening night Friday
nights busy packs now the cool thing was
now everybody's watching this video
probably already knows who the Winter
Soldier ISM yeah I could say now me I
won't serve you something you don't I'm
assuming most of you know who it is it's
on the poster yes they were doing press
junkets together they're all over the
media even as special that Marvel had on
it shows who the actor is they said who
it was said it was right so but it was
cool when we watch there'll be half the
theater when that were was revealed who
the word
bunch of gasps oh my god yeah I was like
wow you really didn't know that that's
what I think that's the thing is that we
always forget that most people who watch
these movies they don't follow movies
and television and comics like in video
games like we do they're not online
watching videos all the time kind of see
what's that unlike us which you guys are
awesome for doing that but yeah so I
thought it was cool that even though I
knew who it was that a lot of people
were like oh yeah yeah well you know
what let's get into our overall thoughts
integrating let's go into a little bit
of spoil sure all right so overall I'm
gonna give it the E - that thing is
fantastic I think it's one of the the
best comic book movies that have been
made it's just not at the top top right
it's just kind of a little bit below
right I think great action and great
story you know other than the
predictable villain right a lot of good
humor so it's just a good time I've seen
it twice a pricey at third time right
yeah I mean I'm gonna go see a second
time for sure I'm gonna give it a b-plus
but please don't think that means that I
like it I don't love it I do love it but
Thor is just my world like I love the
sci-fi / fantasy like Lord of the Rings
meets Star Wars elements gardens of the
galaxy I'm pumped for I just I just love
that science fiction Star Trek II Star
Wars world more that's just that's just
what gets me on that's what people
everybody has something so this was
great I like spy thrillers but I like
sci-fi fantasy more so I like Thor a
dark world a little bit better
but this b-plus go see it I'm gonna go
see the second time you know I thought
it was great
okay all right let's get into sports
sections if you haven't seen it already
don't watch this part but anyways so
yeah the negative thing I said was the
predictable bill I mean you could tell
that Robert Redford was he was good hand
me a few times he was good though no he
was good as good look at him and I like
the reveal of Hydra the real Hydra was
that was a cool scene that like
underground lair with all the computers
and that was great in Arnim Zola is it
Toby John Tobey Joe Joe good afternoon
so but I just didn't like that you knew
from the trailer that Robert Redford was
the bad guy pulling the strings right
when you watch the trailer yeah it's
like oh who else is gonna be here gonna
be him so that was probably my biggest
negative which I didn't
too many oh it was a great movie I mean
just all the characters even this this
new girl the blond girl who was his
neighbor oh she's really Sharon Carter
she's good I liked her yeah she's from
revenge the TV show room yeah revenge
that's where I've seen her phone okay
okay that's right I mean I haven't seen
this you're right people were telling me
that's where she's from yeah she was
good yeah I liked her you know Stan
Lee's cameo was funny yeah oh no I get
this Polly as the I I probably think
that's probably one of my favorite Stan
Lee cameo a little bit forced that one
actually made sense with the plot he
look like he would be yeah he would be
like a museum guard yeah maybe a museum
guard I love and I guess we're jumping
around a little bit I guess I kind of
want to go into if we can to the end the
credits I think that's the most
interesting thing and what's interesting
about it is the fact that we're gonna
sweet guy that we're gonna see quicks
over twice a summer yeah it's different
though because Quicksilver we know is
Magneto's son but you can do them they
can't say that in the Marvel one x-men
one they can so I wonder are these kids
going to be the experiments probably
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver lair
experiments so it's gonna miss you to
see Quicksilver played by the kid from
American Horror Story I always forget
his name the Blancos gonna be in the era
oh yeah I forgot I personally don't like
the look of Quicksilver in the x-men
well okay I like the way they
Quicksilver lives in this Marvel yeah
even though we've only seen a few
pictures and we saw you know 30 seconds
of it in their end credits I like the
way jokes and I like the way Scarlet
Witch look so I'm excited for like a
lose abyss Olsen yeah it gives me hope
for for Avengers 2 which I already and
you know dying to see any race but it is
interesting that we can't they can't use
you know the characters those are
Magneto's kids but they can't use
magneto because Fox owns the rights to
the mutants but but that was cool to see
them and in the very end was it was fine
I mean it was it was night it was kind
of cool to see Sebastian Stan go back
and you know Winter Soldier and look and
take a look at some Monkey Bar stuff and
I think he's just gonna have to discover
who he is on his own and that's fine I
mean and I have a feeling he's going to
end up joining the Avengers
so um capacity I'm gonna go spoilers
here we're already in the spoilers
section but
a little bit beyond so if you have ever
read IDI Brubaker's run on the Winter
Soldier you know
Bucky does eventually replace him now
that might not happen they don't always
follow the cops I don't know this for
sure but we know Sebastian Stan just
signed a nine film deal Chris Evans has
publicly said after his sixth film deal
he's done he once he said I got at
movies directing now like he wants to
move on to other things so maybe he
could take over as Captain or maybe
that's a lighter but I don't think
they're gonna kill Captain know they're
gonna kill Steve Rogers I think they'll
make him go away right and then Bucky
Barnes will take over as Captain America
and then whenever Chris Evans decides
that he wasn't come back yeah or they
hire someone else to be Steve Rogers
that will happen if he was so good Chris
Evans was so good in this movie way he
impressed me more than any other time
I've seen him I mean I like actually
liked him in the Fantastic Four I
thought he was a great Johnny Storm just
cuz how cocky he was and but I mean I
think he's shining this one definitely
yeah and another thing we should mention
even though I think people blew it way
out of proportion
cuz we like everyone some of you guys
know I do AMC movie talk we did a review
of it and we forgot to mention the
Doctor Strange thing and people would
not so like oh my god I can't believe
you didn't talk about it let's let's not
get to override they just mentioned his
name okay that was cool
yeah and I like it and that means that
hey they're leading towards a Doctor
Strange movie hopefully but it's not
like they like showed him or you know I
mean looks like what Mike and I do our
arrow reviews they have the the guy
who's Blue Beetle cord I mean doesn't
mean the rushing to see Blue Beetle I
mean it's cool I mean sometimes I just
throw Easter eggs in it doesn't always
mean those Easter eggs are gonna come to
fruition it could I think if they are I
just say gonna happen I'm just saying it
wasn't enough of a bang that you know
that it should have been oh my god it
was like you have to realize that most
people I mean who see this film like I'm
putting my mom and dad there's one to
see the movie they liked it my dad liked
it for its kind of spice to the rescue
know nature my mom like some Marvel
Universe so but they don't know who
scarlet wishing I mean most of America
like doesn't in the rest of the world
our casual viewers just kind of going to
see a good movie they don't know like
who these people are like when they
showed stano's at the yeah
70 to 80% of the theater was like huh
who was that guy who's this weird
English grey with
big teeth who's this guy we no one knows
who he is yeah and then you know if you
go to luxury more of a fan screaming
alright a press scream everybody knows
everyone said oh my god yeah alright so
yeah cool cool but not a huge huge thing
right I mean it well I'm sure we'll get
dr. strange but it'll be cool to see
that when that comes down the road but
for right now that doesn't mean much for
us now until I mean they said they have
movies planned to what 2028 Kevin Feige
just said so that's a lot of movies but
you don't wonder any well this I mean
this has to die at some point I mean not
forever but with this just keep going
for the next two decades
uh what jabra do you know that's out
right now has gone on this strong for
two in the history I mean if it was only
around for like you know what over a
hundred years but still I know no I'm
not complaining hey I'm not complaining
I love these movies and I think they
won't die but they may lessen to the
fact we're like oh maybe we're not gonna
have five or six comic movies right
there's gotta be
burnout it's some yeah and actually it's
probably even more when you think about
all the kind of things that are based on
non-normal not when you see properties
yeah 300 and all that kind of stuff
then you're gonna have more so I think I
think they'll dwindle down and maybe
we'll get two or three maybe a year
versus right now six seven I mean
luckily right now they're good yeah
that's why we're no one's complaining
cuz they're everyone we've seen
specially Marvel really hasn't missed a
beat since maybe the Incredible Hulk I
like The Incredible Hulk it's okay I
don't mind it's not one of my favorites
okay yeah alright alright guys so that's
what we thought of Captain America the
Winter Soldier you can post your
constable on the website think Ericom or
on our YouTube channel think hero pro
make sure to subscribe to that and also
come find us on Twitter I would talk to
Destin I bought cats in America what did
you think in the movie we just think of
the end and the mid credits and the
final credits scene what are you looking
forward to how excited are you for
gardens the galaxy or at think here or
I'm at Griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think hero fans make sure you like that
page and share our videos on Twitter and
Facebook and other social media
you